[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt wir sind hier gerade in der nähe
vom neusiedler see in österreich und in
meiner letzten folge habe ich hier schon
gesehen wie honig gewonnen wird
heute geht's hier um diese pflanze das
ist keine lauchzwiebeln sondern
knoblauch normalerweise kennt man
knobloch hier wirklich nur als
knoblauchknollen getrocknet vom
supermarkt hier haben wir eine richtig
tolle knoblauch pflanze und man kann
sogar das grün und hier oben die
knoblauch blüte verwerten und wie das
ganze funktioniert erklären wir jetzt
gleich christian ehrich die sind hinten
schon auf dem feld
hallo jetzt 2 hallo schön euch zu sehen
zur begrüßung an einen strauß voller
knobloch knoblauch blüten also das habe
ich auch noch nicht bekommen zur
begrüßung
den kann man wahrscheinlich zu hause
aufstellen dann riecht alles ein
bisschen nach knoblauch besser werden zu
kochen direkt erste gemüse correas erste
gemüse japans und chinas in österreich
deutschland kennt das nicht weiter ob
bei uns wird nicht verwendet leider und
ist sowas hochwertig ist und so was
großartiges im geschmack die
spitzengastronomie kennst natürlich aber
normal verbraucher leider nicht ich
glaube das halten wir ändern am besten
mit diesem video
[Gelächter]
ja man sieht hier dass der knoblauch
eben wurzeln hat eine knolle hat hier
blätter hat ganz spannend jeder
knoblauch hat neun blätter 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9
knoblauch gehört zur königsdisziplin von
gemüse bei der vier jahreszeiten
durchlebt das heißt er wird im herbst
gepflanzt wächst dann über den winter
jetzt ist frühling kommt jetzt im sommer
dann in einem buch wieder geerntet das
heißt nur wenn alle die jahreszeiten
wirklich dem knoblauch gefallen
dann ist die ernte auch großen zufrieden
stellen und werden die ersten drei
blätter wie hier sind zwei wenn die
ersten drei blätter trocken sein dann
beginnt die antwort an israel dann
knobloch wird wirklich viel angetan
der hat man schält in das ist wirklich
für ihn
katastrophe das ist so wie wenn man den
menschen die haut unterschiedlich und
das wird schön hergerichtet hin zum
markt wird nun das überhaupt nicht
christa und erich haben es geschafft
dass ihr knoblauch in österreich quasi
frisch vom feld im ganzen im interspar
verkauft werden darf die knoblauch
knolle ist nicht schmutzig sondern ehrt
betont wdr ich jetzt sagen würde
das hat den vorteil dass die knolle ein
jahr lang haltbar ist weil sie vom laub
zerrt die einzige auflage von der
lebensmittelbehörde ist back tim dann so
ein interview nichts geworden
was macht ja auch nicht jeder supermarkt
mit normalerweise sind ja obst und
gemüse sollten auch genauigkeit von
bananen
das wenn die banane zu kommen oder zu
gerade ist fliegt sie weg wenn die
tomate zu groß oder zu klein ist fliegt
sie weg als landen ja täglich und
monatlich tonnenweise lebensmittel auf
dem müll unnötigerweise ja vorhin habe
ich ja kurz erzählt darf man wirklich
den kompletten knoblauch benutzen kann
die knolle klar das kennt jeder man
könnte wirklich eine trilogie aus dem
knoblauch machen das heißt aus dem jung
knoblich wie es jetzt überhaupt ist ganz
ohne knoblauch cremesuppe mit einem
grünen schaum der blätter dann zeigen
wir natürlich noch was wir aus den
blüten machen und aus dem stängel
außerdem stehen gekommen haben wirklich
tolle vorspeisen machen
er wird dann gebraten mit der jetta
balsamico viertels ist das vorstellen so
wandelten die puppe kann dann ja man
verwendet dem disk am 10
die wurzeln kann man frittieren und dann
auf die suppe bestreuen und dann hat man
ein wirklich eine trilogie von knobloch
und hat wirklich alles verwendet weil er
wirklich wert verlieren falls ihr auch
totale knoblauch fansite und die finger
von der richtige knolle nicht lassen
könnt und euer partner sich schon
beschwert weil er das zimmer nicht
betreten kann
dann gibt es hier den ultimativen tipp
von mir laut einer studie ist das beste
mittel gegen knoblauch ein glas milch
oder auch ein strauch petersilie das
darin enthaltene chlorophyll
neutralisiert den knoblauchgeruch aber
eine komplette neutralisierung geht
nicht da das schwefelhaltige allicin zu
stark ist und auch trotzdem über die
haut riecht also am besten immer in
gesellschaft knoblauch essen
ihr habt ihr hier nicht nur den
knoblauch den er beim interspar anbietet
sondern auch ganz viele tolle weitere
produkte und die können wir
wahrscheinlich bei euch im laden sehen
oder wir könnten den strommarkt zudem
maulbeerbäumen das sind gleich daneben
dort haben wir 400 maut beim enterprise
software naschen da brauchen wir uns
unterwegs ja einmal werden und dann
gehen uns euch einladen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
damit ihr kurzerhand beschlossen noch zu
kochen wein nicht auf dem plan
christa consoli das geht so schnell
jetzt nehmen wir hier diese knoblauch
blüten gern warum schneiden hier denn
die spitze ab und oben den stängel
halbieren sie und dann kommen sie schon
in die pfanne
[Musik]
[Applaus]
totale kommt uns jetzt aber nicht nur
entdeckt wie knoblauch angebaut wird und
wie er aussieht und dass man alles vom
flug noch verwerten kann sondern direkt
vom blitz verteilt jetzt laufe am besten
noch über den laden
denn ihr habt ihr nicht der knoblauch so
noch für das andere und wir laufen alle
kaufen aber definitiv
[Musik]
aber wirklich gut gestärkt und ich kann
immer noch nicht glauben wie gut
knoblauch böten schmecken also wirklich
da hamma unvergleichbar wirklich richtig
toll
falls ihnen bauern oder ein landwirt bei
euch in der nähe hat der knoblauch
anbaut unbedingt probieren und ich habe
wirklich gelernt dass es kein
abfallprodukt ist sondern eine
delikatesse
jetzt stehen wir hier bei euch ja aber
sally wir am nicht nur knoblauch wie wir
vorher gekocht haben sondern wir haben
hier in unserem shop der ist 17
quadratmeter airbus haben jahr 30.000
besucher wir haben 50 produkte ungefähr
die wir einlegen
das wichtigste ist uns den geschmack ins
chaos zu kriegen und interspar hat
österreichweit eine schöne auswahl auch
eine kleine auswahl aber schöne
aufwallung christliche in ganz
österreich auch verträge und damit ihr
auch was von den produkten bekommt weil
sie jetzt keine winterschuhe für euch
ihr habt was natürlich sehr schade wäre
haben wir hier noch ein kleines paket
für euch wieder ein kleines gewinnspiel
dazu solltet ihr einfach nur folgende
frage beantworten wie viele blätter
hatten eine knoblauch pflanze also wer
im video gut aufgepasst hat weiß auf
jeden fall die antwort und dann bekommt
ihr dieses paket zugeschickt da sind
wirklich ganz schöne ausgewählte
delikatessen dabei unter anderem auch
knobloch flöten was ich dir denn
besonders am herzen
was mir am herzen liegt und was so schön
wo ich glaube daran dass sie noch von
uns ist dass wir die vielfalt hier
kultivieren die vielfalt auch für eine
zukunft weil sollte sich das klima
wandelt sollte irgend etwas in der welt
passieren wo ja nicht nur wir sondern
auch die nächsten und übernächsten
generation noch wunderbar köstliches
obst und gemüse essen
wie macht ihr das indem wir eben 3200
tomatensorten kultivieren die samen
aufheben wir haben 6 700 sorten chili
und paprika marca wachsen jetzt 30
solchen zwiebel und 30 sarah es ist auch
eine zwiebel ich glaube der normale
haushalt kennt ja nur rote zwiebel weiße
zwiebel frühlingszwiebel ja richtig bei
uns gibt es viel mehr aber spar
interspar haben auch von unseren zwiebel
sorgt nur 14
wenn ich dachte und da haben wir eine
besonders schöne auswahl und süßen
zwiebel sie kriegen über frankreich
spanien und so richtig teuren sie kuchen
bekommen also nicht nur was für jetzt
wie die gegenwart für den tollen
geschmack sondern auch was für die
zukunft ich fand's wirklich super schön
dass ich hier bei euch sein dürfte und
natürlich auch dass ich euch das ganze
wissen jetzt ein bisschen mit geben
konnte schreibt mir auf jeden fall wir
euch dieses video gefallen hat ich hoffe
ihr habt ein bisschen was mitgenommen
und wenn ihr nicht gerade wie ein foto
und den knoblauch allergien haben dann
probiert auf jeden fall mal knoblauch
blüten und verwertet vor allem die
komplette knop nach pflanze ich hoffe
ihr habt spaß dabei und guten appetit
freunde habt ihr dann vielleicht keine
mehr denn ich schon ein bisschen aber
wenn alle davon essen ist es völlig okay
es gibt natürlich auch noch weitere
videos von meiner österreich zieht dürft
ihr euch gerne anschauen also bis zum
nächsten mal
[Musik]